We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P here
is a caller who is not happy with me.
Take a listen.
David, this is Robert and Riverside too.
You are driving me insane with calling her
tool fee.
Gabard or Gabbard or whatever you come up
with.
Her name is Tulsi Gabard.
I know toolsy is probably because she's a
Russian tool.
Jesus.
Dude, please stop.
Yeah, just remember English is my second language
and I do the bag.
What we know when I try to say Amy Klobuchar
car, I sometimes make a mistake when I see
it say say tool Gabbert it could be wrong.
Uh, I'm doing the best I can here.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Remember those bridge gate convictions for
that completely outrageous George Washington
bridge scandal.
Several years ago, the Supreme court might
toss out the bridge gate convictions.
We'll tell you why on the bonus show, Donald
Trump is slamming Apple for refusing to unlock
the iPhones of suspected criminals and we're
going to talk about that and encryption and
data security and so many other things including
due process, and we will talk about Donald,
one of Donald Trump's former national security
advisors, not the most recent one, but one
of the earlier ones.
Michael Flynn, the indicted Michael Flynn.
Michael Flynn now wants to withdraw his guilty
plea altogether.
We will tell you why and we will tell you
what the likely repercussions of that are.
How, where is that happening?
Where, how do you get access to that?
That's the bonus show.
The bonus show happens every day.
It's in addition to the broadcast show.
It's an extra show we do every day.
Pat joins me for the show Monday through Thursday.
Friday.
Pat hosts the bonus show.
subscribe@joinpacman.com to get instant access.
Become a patron@atleastthefivedollaramonthlevelatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show to get instant access.
All good ways to get access to the world famous
bonus show where things continue.
Otherwise we will see you on tomorrow's show,
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].